I'm told that you before you go you had
you brought some gifts that's right
they're from your you are a serious if
very talented woodworker craftsman maker
of things I'm always learning to make
things with wood it is very healthy it
keeps me out of the pub yeah this is the
thing but it's I mean it involves the
part of your brain that likes to do
puzzles and that is very healthy it
keeps you sharp I have a business in
town called Offerman woodshop comm yep
and we we just ran out of these but I
brought you these in general because for
all the holidays we have these cards of
American cherry as American cherry wood
right yeah I'm just gonna display these
right now cuz he do such lovely work I
wrote you a note on this one I wouldn't
mind if you're a real stud no look
closer tonin please don't diminish this
gesture with some disingenuous foppery
yeah very nice now in New York in LA
it's opening nationwide this Friday
there's no better man than Nick Offerman
and I'll say
[Applause]
you